l'importance des entreprises d'orange
air n'est plus à démontrer en 2019
on estime que ce sont 13 % des salariés
en france qui travaillaient pour des
firmes sous contrôle étranger
cela représente quand même selon l'insee
plus de 2 millions de français c'est pas
rien la france s'était d'ailleurs
l'année dernière le pays européen le
plus attractif pour les entreprises
étrangères
avec 11% d'investissements
supplémentaires et 40000 emplois en plus
créé par rapport à l'année précédente
bref les étrangers exem bien la france
et on peut s'en réjouir
c'est bon pour l'économie mais parce
qu'il ya un mais bien évidemment le
locaux vides
et n'allez pas croire que je fais une
fixette mais le coc vide remet un peu
tout à plat en europe tous les pays sont
touchés et d économie plombée et donc ça
refroidit fortement les investisseurs
étrangers qui sont au taquet sur les
plans de relance des différents pays
européens qui doivent pour les rassurer
faire de la pédagogie les brosser dans
le sens du poil en ordonnant en quelque
sorte des garanties sur le fait que
l'économie se portera bientôt lieu et
que c'est donc dans leur intérêt de
mettre de l'argent sur la table
c'est ce qu'a fait emmanuel macron avec
notamment ce sommet virtuel chose crowns
on peut difficilement faire plus clair
comme titre reste à savoir si ça
marchera en plein confinement unis
s'inquiètent en priorité pour les
entreprises françaises et on tente par
exemple de boycotter des entreprises
étrangères comme amazon
[Musique]